noticias interesantes de la salud con
más Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela ayer se publicó un
estudio en de lanced sobre el impacto
del cambio climático Cuáles son las
principales conclusiones si es un
estudio que forma parte del global
Countdown que periódicamente publican
datos sobre el cambio climático y su
impacto en la salud esta vez la
diferencia es que es específicamente en
la región Sudamericana Y definitivamente
uno de los titulares es el aumento en
las últimas dos décadas por las muertes
por calor por las olas de calor en total
son 160 por ciento más muertes entre
2017 y 2021 En comparación con el 2000 y
el 2004 los países donde más ha
aumentado es Ecuador donde las muertes
por calor se ha multiplicado
prácticamente en un 10% llegó a la 1400
por ciento de aumento en estas dos
décadas pero también se menciona Guyana
se menciona chile y los países donde
menos afectación hay ha sido en Paraguay
Argentina y Uruguay sin embargo que así
sea por ejemplo paraguayo uno de los
países donde menos ha aumentado igual ha
sido un 143% claramente no es una buena
noticia además el estudio Calcula que
las pérdidas económicas por estas
muertes equivalen a 485.000 salarios
medios de 2021 en cada en cada país es
decir que el impacto no es solo en
pérdidas de vida sino también económico
Esto está directamente relacionado con
la exposición a los días de calor tanto
para los niños como para los adultos
mayores que son dos de las poblaciones
más vulnerables en este sentido arriba
vemos la exposición a días de calor para
los niños abajo para los adultos mayores
y vemos un aumento claro a partir del
2010 aproximadamente no Brasil en color
verde claro es uno de los países más
afectados también Venezuela esta
exposición a días de calor provoca por
ejemplo deshidratación aumento de
presión arterial enfermedades
cardiovasculares empeora enfermedades
respiratorias y también a largo plazo y
por ejemplo en la población como los
niños el calor las olas de calor afectan
mucho al dormir mal que también sabemos
que puede tener eso implicaciones
negativas a largo plazo bueno otra
consecuencia del cambio climático es la
expansión de enfermedades como el dengue
que antes tenían más prominencia en
algunas regiones del mundo ya no es así
ya no es así no son enfermedades
infecciosas que aumentan y no a futuro
sino que ya está sucediendo
especialmente eso porque hay más calor
por lo tanto el hábitat es más amigable
para que los mosquitos que es el vector
del dengue se reproduzcan y se expandan
a otras enfermedades en estos gráficos
vemos el aumento de lo que se llama el
número de reproducción de la enfermedad
en los últimos años este número
significa Cuántos casos se originan a
partir de un caso es decir una persona
contagiada Cuántos contagios más nuevos
va a generar y vemos un aumento
sostenido en Brasil Bolivia Colombia
Perú también Venezuela que no hemos
podido incluirlo en el gráfico por
ejemplo en Colombia un caso de dengue ya
pasa a ser 3,5 casos nuevos no es un
aumento muy claro desde unos en 1950 de
media este número de reproducción ha
aumentado 0,53% cada año ha ido
aumentando progresivamente y hay países
en los que por supuesto no ha aumentado
tanto que no tenían tanta presencia de
la enfermedad Como países del cono Sur
Argentina Uruguay también pero eso no
significa que no se esté expandiendo a
estas zonas como decías antes que eran
más temperadas o que en los países
tropicales suban a más altura donde las
temperaturas también son más bajas no
respecto por ejemplo el informe destaca
la década de los 50 el aumento total ha
sido Del 35%. se prevé además marque la
inseguridad alimentaria también aumente
y esto es un tema Si bien que empeora
por el cambio climático también tiene
mucho que ver con voluntad política Pero
bueno vamos a hablar de la investigación
no tiene mucho que ver con voluntad
política porque sabemos que en América
Latina y en Sudamérica por ejemplo se
tira se desaprovecha mucha de la comida
que se produce Entonces eso es
importante tenerlo en cuenta pero en
este caso también vamos a hablar
directamente del impacto del clima y en
este caso tiene mucho que ver el tiempo
adecuado que hay para que las los
cultivos crezcan cada vez hay menos días
de clima adecuado digamos para que estos
cultivos crezcan en todos los casos en
el trigo en que hemos incluido las dos
cifras porque hay una un cultivo digamos
de invierno y uno de verano en los
países donde tiene esta estacionalidad
ha disminuido el tiempo adecuado para
cultivar un dos coma dos o dos coma
cinco por ciento sucede algo parecido
con el maíz con el arroz o con la soya y
eso tiene un impacto en dos direcciones
uno económico porque en la región
Sudamericana la agricultura es un insumo
muy importante pero también como
decíamos en términos de consumo de
alimentos y esto es en un continente en
una región Mejor dicho donde el 40% de
la población ya vive en inseguridad
alimentaria entonces bueno no tener
acceso a la salud a la salud perdón a
los alimentos se relaciona como decíamos
con una mortalidad prematura también con
enfermedades cardiovasculares no tener
una dieta balanceada no porque los
alimentos son muy caros Entonces eso
además lo vamos a ver probablemente las
consecuencias mucho más a largo plazo no
los niños de ahora que no están pudiendo
comer bien probablemente tendrán muchas
más enfermedades cuando lleguen por
ejemplo los 50 años y en nuestros países
esto casi que raya la vergüenza amar
Cuáles son las recomendaciones para
evitar que la situación empeore así pues
en el grupo de investigación uno hizo
una batería de recomendaciones del
informe está disponible en abierto para
que los puedan revisar pero vamos a dar
algunos ejemplos no por ejemplo Aires
más limpios que podrían ayudar a que la
contaminación en las ciudades no sea tan
grave no provoque tantas muertes
prematuras se registraron 37.000 en 2020
a partir de estas partículas que están
en la contaminación atmosférica otra de
las recomendaciones que más llamó la
atención también es que las economías
sudamericanas muchas subsidian la
economía las energías fósiles no Y estos
subsidios según Los investigadores del
estudio representan de media el 10% del
presupuesto de salud entonces una de las
sugerencias que hacen en el estudio es
que estos subsidios de la energía fósil
que sabemos que es uno de los vale
responsables de las emisiones de gases
invernaderos puedan redirigirse a
adaptar mejor los sistemas de salud a
protegerlos y prepararlos de cara al
futuro Sabiendo todo lo que se viene y
también pues a garantizar digamos un
acceso equitativo a la salud sabemos que
no es fácil porque no subsidiar los
precios de la gasolina luego tiene
muchos otros impactos en la economía que
también pueden revertir negativamente en
la población Pero bueno Esto es
básicamente lo que recomiendan un
énfasis muy importante en este acceso
igualitario a los servicios de salud
pues gracias a usted mar por abordarlo
de manera integral y nos vemos mañana
nos vemos mañana